[Music]
developing at five tonight we're
learning some new information about two
hotel projects on the north end of the
strip let's start with the first one
here the former fountain blue building
slated to be now the jw marriott las
vegas boulevard a marriott spokesperson
tells 8 news now the company exited the
project and in a statement fountain blue
development tells us the original vision
for the building is back on they say the
hotel will be managed and operated by
fountain blue development county
commissioner tick seeger bloom says it's
a prime location
with the new convention center being
built uh and the economy coming back
that hopefully another major partner
like that will come back because
it's really an eyesore and and one thing
i'm committed to is making the building
at least look better so it's more
presentable
meanwhile another developer plans to
break ground on the majestic hotel right
across the street from the new
convention center hall kind of around
the corner from fountain blue according
to the website construction should begin
early next year it's described as
non-gaming non-smoking but it will be
ultra luxury completion listed for 2024.